everyone I'm Kristen Gill your host of
how to Hollywood and today I'm going to
be doing this Kristen Bell inspired
tutorial from the SAG Awards she looked
amazing and I spoke to her makeup artist
Simone Siegel and she gave me all of the
details on what went into this look and
I actually have a couple products of the
makeup that she wore that night so if
you guys want to learn how to recreate
this look please keep watching
[Music]
Simone told me that there were three key
components is the lip the eyes and the
skin care she's all about skin care she
says and she used all Neutrogena
products they used things like hydro
boost sheet mask and the hydro water gel
and eye cream I already have my skin
prepped I have my foundation on and my
concealer I did not use Neutrogena
because I don't normally use it but she
did use the hydro boost hydrating tint
foundation and the concealer stick to go
along with that and I just have my
bronzer already on my blush already on
and I'm just going to get started right
into the eyes because that was one of
the key components getting ready to host
tonight stick with me for all the fun
and fantasy that will happen backstage
before I inevitably ruin my show so
first I started out with a crease color
just a couple shades darker than my own
skin tone actually something that I use
for bronzer and now I'm going to start
with the lid I'm just going to be using
a flat shader brush like this one so she
also used the Neutrogena nourishing long
wear eye shadow and built-in primer
those shades look pretty shimmery right
here this is in the color cool plum and
she also used Coco mauve I don't have
Coco Mob today but I do have the cool
plum and I'm just going to go right in
with this pink shade right here these
are all shimmery shades so that's why I
went in with the crease color first now
I'm just going to pack this on the lid
Simone went with a smokey eye for the
night and it started in the inner corner
it was pretty light and then it just
really smoked out into kind of a plummy
color to match her dress and that is my
goal today and then using a fluffy brush
I'm
going to use the brown shade in that
palette and I'm just going to go in the
outer corner of my lid and use
windshield wiper motions I'm just going
to buff that in the crease and be really
light handed the further you keep your
hand out on the brush the lighter your
strokes will be and these colors in this
palette really made her eyes pop
especially on that red carpet this is
the look we're doing and she was wearing
that very colored J Mendel dress the
strapless gown it was gorgeous and the
eyes just really everything was so tied
together with the nude lip it was a
perfect complement to this strong smoky
eye simone also told me that she chose a
smoky eye because she said that kristin
looks so glamorous in one wanted it to
be a strong look because you're the
first host of the SAG Awards so she
really wanted to make a classic
statement and I really think that they
did Jenny chode said that they chose all
updos because they loved Kristin's jaw
line it's very strong and when her hair
is up it's really prominent okay now I'm
using the modern renaissance palette
from Anastasia Beverly Hills this wasn't
on Simone's list but I don't have the
Mavi shades that she had for this look
and the antique bronze in my Anastacio
Beverly Hills palette is very Movil so
I'm going to use a little bit of that
just to go in the crease to create a
little more of that berry tone that she
had I'm just going to push that in with
that same brush that I used to create
that crease just push it into the outer
corner kind of in the outer V push that
and then just buff it in right here
all about blending you guys she also
told me that she didn't use lashes which
I was very surprised Kristin has some
amazing lashes to be able to be on stage
and in all of that kind of lighting and
to not wear false lashes is huge it
looked amazing and she also said that
she didn't use any eyeliner she just
used a brown shadow so I'm going to be
using the Neutrogena pal
for that with that brown shadow I'm just
going to go along my lash line and
that's it like it was actually a pretty
simple look she was all over the place
obviously hosting is a huge gig it was
all about changing that lip out as quick
as possible and back on stage
I am Kristen Bell and I am a narcissist
[Applause]
bringing it a little bit down on the
lower lash line
just to connect so I don't want anything
looking too purpley down here it doesn't
look like she has anything on that
bottom lash line except for a little bit
of that brown eye shadow but I don't
want there to be a gap just to build up
that outer corner a little bit more I'm
going to use an angled brush and I'm
just going to go in with that purple
shade in the Neutrogena palette at the
very bottom of the cool plum palette to
keep those berry colors bring in a
little bit of a purpley tone not too
much buff that in with a clean brush
I think whereas smokey as I want to get
let's do the eyeliner I'm going to use
another angled brush and I'm using that
brown shade from the Neutrogena palette
right here and we're just going to
create some eyeliner and the cool thing
about using eyeshadow is eyeliner is
that you don't have to make it super
perfect it can look really soft and just
kind of buffed into your lash line so
don't worry if you're not great at
eyeliner eyeshadow is the best bet to
use so we're just pushing that brown
shadow into the lash line and Simone
said that she did it midway through the
eye so she started about where your iris
is right here and went over and built it
up on this outer crease you didn't bring
it in at all on this side I'm also going
in with Cyprus amber from that modern
renaissance palette just because it's
matte and it's a little bit darker and
easier to build up
okay so with that same brown shade and a
flat shader brush like this it's just
kind of like the angled brush but it's
more square I'm just going to use a
little bit of that Cypress umber and the
brown shade from Neutrogena and just tap
them together to mix them and I'm just
putting that right along my lash line
where you lay your brush first the most
product is going to go so you want to
make sure that you have that smoked
outside on the outside edge and then
bring whatever is left on your brush to
the middle so same goes for the bottom
she didn't bring it all the way in
either she just brought it right to the
middle okay so now I'm going to use a
little bit of mascara
she obviously used Neutrogena mascaras
use the hydro boost but I am going to be
using my maneater mascara from Tarte so
I'm just going to do three coats of
mascara on the top and bottom and that
should cover it okay I'm done with the
eyes so for the last component of the
look there was a lip the red carpet look
like I'm doing right now is the color
pillow-talk and this is the matte
revolution lipstick from Charlotte
Tilbury it's just this beautiful nude
and simone told me that the lip color
which was specific to each look and
dress she wanted it to be classy elegant
fresh and fun and I really think she
nailed that because obviously on the red
carpet the dress spoke for itself she
had a subtle lip the bold eye and then
when she was onstage she wore beautiful
Rima accra and she wore Yamina Couture
as the last final dress and she just
looked phenomenal with the berry lips
that she chose for those those were
actually Dutchess glastonbury and love
berry so she actually used four
different lipsticks
for the looks hello talk is the one that
I've been throwing around right now so
this is the one I'm going to be using
she did say she used a Neutrogena lip
primer before because sometimes berry
lips can bleed
use the Neutrogena hydro boost lip
treatment as the primer I'm just going
to pop this on and then we're done with
the look you don't even need a lip liner
with this because it's so pointed at the
tip simone told me that she came up with
all of the looks the lips to the looks
with Jenny Cho the hair stylist like I
said before and Nicole Jabez who did all
of the styling for the night and she
said it was a true team effort it's
always a collaboration with the three of
them and Kristen looked phenomenal as
the first host of the SAG Awards if you
guys liked this video please like and
subscribe to entertainment tonight's
YouTube channel and I will see you in
the next one bye guys
you